Through American cosmic. And in general,
you've attracted with much of the UFO community.
You mentioned you follow just by the ways that you will
follow adjusts or is it you follow adjusts,
you follow first of all, what is the you follow adjust?
And second of all, um, what have you learned about this, uh,
community of euphology lists or also as you refer to them as, uh,
the invisibles or the members of the invisible college,
or just in general, people who study your photos from the different,
all the different kinds of groups of study? UFO's sure.
Generally what I found is that they are, okay.
So people who are interested in your photos from like being a kid, you know,
and seeing some cool movie like star Wars or something,
and then they become interested in,
then they study it as best they can UFO's or UAPs.
They're generally an honest group of people who are using their
tools. And there are generally two types of them. Um,
there are those who believe in the nuts and bolts,
like the physical craft and they believe in that these are things from other
planets. Okay. So that's like the T H hypothesis, uh, you know,
um, I'm sorry. E T hypothesis ETH is what we call it. Yeah. Sorry about that.
So this is like, there's an actual spaceship, like a physical,
like something akin, but much more advanced than the rockets we use now.
And there's some kind of,
not necessarily biological,
but something like biological organisms that travel on these.
So this would be like what to the stars Academy is trying to decipher,
like how, you know, how do they do it? You know,
maybe we could use that technology, the propulsion and things like that.
They look at the rocket technology. Okay. So there are those,
and then there are people who believe that it's more consciousness based. Okay.
So these are your two types of, um, you follow just who are known.
And these are people who we know about.
Then I found that there are people who are quote unquote,
I call them the invisibles because jock valet in the, in the seventies,
he, and, um, I think actually, Alan, Hynek his colleague quoted,
this is a Francis bacon thing. By the way,
it goes back to the early modern time period when scientists could be killed for
basically trying to go outside where the church or the government
institution determined was dogma. And so they had to be really careful.
So they call, he called it the invisible college.
So Hynek took that term and return, re-used it? Or what do you call it?
Repurposed it.
So he repurposed it so that they were still talking to each other though.
So what I found to be the case was that there was a group of people who were
scientists, but were not on the internet, you know,
10 people today and students of mine in particular and my own kids.
Actually,
they think that you only exist if you're on the internet or something really
exists if it's on the internet and that's of course untrue.
And so what I found was that there are most people who are the most powerful
people of our society and are doing things are not on the internet.
You're not going to find a trace of them.
So a lot of these people are what I call invisibles.
People who are studying, at least their work is invisible.
You might find them on the internet,
but you're going to find that they're part of the bowling league or something
like that. Right.
You will not find that they are actually engaged in research about this
topic. Okay.
And so I called them the invisibles because I was surprised to find them.
And I thought, well, this is no longer the invisible college,
because these people are not even talking to each other.
And that's why I reference this movie fight, clip in it.
You have an invisible. Okay. And his name is Tyler Durden.
And he's incredible. He does incredible things. Um,
he's like a person who should not exist. Right.
Because he does so many things that are amazing.
And so I find a person like that and I call, and he's a real person. Um,
he's partially on the internet,
but nothing that he does around that topic of UFO's is on the internet.
So I decided to call him Tyler, D T after Tyler Durden. And so these people, I,
um, I've turned the UFO fight club because they work together,
but they don't know. In fact, his boss doesn't know what he does.
They don't talk to each other because you know, the first rule of fight club.
Same as the second. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah, no, you don't do it.
Why do you have a sense that, um, there's such a,
um, I don't want to say fear, but a principle of staying out of the limelight.
I think there's something real. And I think that the use of it could be, um,
dangerous for people.
Oh, sorry. You mean like something real, like there's actual techno I don't,
what's the right terminology to hear to you alien technology
ideas about technology that are being explored
that are dangerous of made public. That may be become dangerous public.
I wouldn't cut. You don't have to call it alien alien technology.
You can call it ideas about alien technology,
because I don't know if it's actual alien technology or not.
I honestly don't know, but I do know for a fact,
because it's a historical fact that Jack Parsons and, um,
Constantine Schakowsky,
who's Russian believed in these things and believe that they were downloading
this information, whether or not they were, I don't, I mean,
they definitely created the rocket technologies.
That's true how they did and whether their process was
exactly what they said it was. I don't know. So this is the same thing today.
So we've got some powerful technologies going on here and you know,
of course we have a military and we have a military for a reason. Every,
almost every government he needs, the military has one. Um,
and so they're going to, um,
keep these the way they should be kept in my interpretation. I mean,
think about it. Everybody accepts the fact that we have a military,
almost everybody does.
Why are they so upset then that the military keeps secrets?
Yeah, well, that's,
that's the nature of things we can get into that whole thing. I, I, uh, I,
I tend to, I've spoken with the CTO of Lockheed Martin on this.
Um, I've obviously read and think about war a lot.
It's such a difficult question because the space,
this particular space of technology,
there's a gray area that I think is evolving over time.
I think nuclear weapons change the game in terms of what should,
and shouldn't be secret.
I think there's already technology that will enable us to destroy each other.
And so there's some sense in which some technology should be made public.
This is the same discussion of, um, you know, uh, between companies,
which part of your technology should you make public through?
Like for example, academic publications and all that kind of stuff.
I call the Google search engine works page rank algorithm,
or how the different deep learning,
like those pretty vibrant machine learning research communities within Google,
Facebook and so on. And they release a lot of different ideas.
It's an interesting question.
Like how dangerous is it to release some of the ideas?
I think it's a gray area that's constantly changing.
I do also think it's super interesting.
I wonder if you could elaborate on a little bit that there's this
gray area between what's actually real in terms of
alien technology and the belief of it
when held in the minds of really brilliant people that they ultimately may
produce the same kind of result in terms of being able to create
new technologies that are human usable,
like is there, um,
in your mind,
they're one in the same as like believing in alien craft
and, uh, actually being in possession of an alien craft.
I don't think they're the same. No belief is powerful. Okay. Um,
in new age communities, you know, people think thoughts are things okay.
That's been said, you know,
thoughts are things you can make them happen kind of thing.
Believe in them enough.
It is true that if I believe I can run a
five 40 mile, I'll do it. Okay. And I probably will do it.
And I've done it before. Actually I'm much younger, but I did it.
So, but my coach is the one that instilled that belief in me. Right. And so,
but can I run like one minute mile? No. Okay.
So I guess, does that answer your question? Like there's only,
so belief goes in generating reality.
Well, yeah. I mean, I guess that's what, uh, just having listened to Jack valet,
it seemed like reality is not,
was not as important for the scientific exploration of the concept of alien
technology.
I could be wrong, but this is what I think shocks getting at.
There were other ways to access places in reality,
other than what we consider to be physical. Right. That's this consciousness.
Okay. So in, like I said,
so religious studies is among other things. It's just,
it's looking at visionary experiences. All right.
So people do have visionary experiences. They did without drugs, you know,
they did with drugs, they do with drugs.
They do many have them without drugs today.
And oftentimes those visionary experiences, um,
correspond to each other now, how do we, how do we make sense of that? So,
you know, do these places actually exist in a sense, I think they do.
And so I think that, you know,
like let's take that very famous case of a Virgin Mary operation in Fatima,
where I think there was like a lot of people, thousands and thousands, if not,
like, I think 50,000 or something like that, a lot of people, uh,
gathered to see what's now called the miracle of
Fatima, which was the spinning of the sun will,
a lot of people saw different things, but they all saw some kind of thing.
Okay. So they all saw different things, but it was, uh, something happened.
Okay. So I guess the question is, um,
what are these places where we access non
what I'd call like non-physical realities. Okay.
Where we actually do get information. We did get, like,
who could say that Jack Parsons didn't get information from doing these rituals
and accessing these. We have to say that he actually did,
because we see the results of physical results, the same thing with Tyler.
And that's why I put Tyler in this camp with this tradition with
Jack persons. I say that Tyler is, is getting these,
what he calls downloads. And you can see the results of them physically.
He sells them on the NASDAQ. He makes millions of dollars from them. He,
they help people. I've seen people who they've helped.